(man)
Perfect matches is filmed
before a live studio audience.
(newscaster) Tonight on the 7:15
news, is your husband cheating
on you
with a hotter woman?
Wait, what?
(laughing)
(cheering and applause)
Are you cheating
on me?
(laughing)
Shhh.
The Girl
Scouts are comin'.
So?
So, I owe 'em $2,000.
(laughing)
(woman)
Hello,
anyone there?
Oh my God.
They got in
the back door.
(laughing)
Here...
Hide under this.
(laughing)
When's lunch?
(cheering)
It's just Amy.
I thought you were
a Girl Scout.
Thanks.
Going sailing?
(laughing)
Actually, I'm about to go
take care of some business.
(laughing)
I'm terrified.
I think Ralphie's
cheating on me.
With what,
a doughnut hole?
(slight laughter)
(cheering)
(whooping and whistling)
Don't you knock?
We don't knock.
The postman
always rings twice.
(laughing)
You look
very nice, Amy.
I like your haircut.
(audience "ooooh"ing)
Aren't you just supposed
to deliver the mail
and not pickup lines?
Come on.
When are you going
to let me take you out?
Huh?
(cheering and clapping)
Your breath's already
doing it from there.
(a few laughs)
(cheering)
Candy!
Hey!
(whooping)
Anybody see Candy?
Ralphie, every day
of his life.
Hey, uh, ease up
on the fat jokes.
That's my
scripted line.
You're blowing
this.
Hey, are
those new jeans?
I like 'em.
Oh, yeah...
Thanks.
Is there a mirror
in your pocket,
because I sure can
see myself in 'em.
(one man clears throat)
'Cause that would mean that
we would have had sex.
(man)
We heard you.
(Bonnie)
No one is even
listening to me.
I think Ralphie's
seeing someone else.
(laughing)
Well, we know it's
not his feet.
(man)
No.
What the (bleep) is
going on today?
(hooting, toilet flushing)
Hey, everybody, I just took a
huge dump 'cause I'm so fat.
(loud laughing)
Ralphie, you're
not that fat.
For a sperm whale.
(groaning)
Why?
No, every joke is that he's
so fat and you guys love it.
(booing)
No, no, (bleep) you.
What-- no.
This show is
not funny.
It's disgusting.
It's a horrible depiction
of an Indian man, first of all.
When is lunch?
(uproarious laughter)
No.
You're all
(bleep) sheep.
These jokes aren't
funny.
You're just used to the
rhythms and laughing at them!
No!
(crowd chanting)
Where are you
taking me?
(cheering and clapping)
(screaming, gun fires)
Amy?
You look
different.
Yeah, you know,
I feel different.
(laughing)
Honey, I've
got terrible news.
(gasping)
Are you
cheating on me?
No, the toilet's
broken.
(laughing)
I was so scared,
jinga-binga-boom.
You got nothing to
bow-wawow-wowow.
(laughing)
Dubba-lubba-dubba-chowm-chowm.
La-la-la-lala-la.
(silence)
Hey,
badda-boom-bop-boom.
(laughing)
When's lunch?
(cheering, music playing)
(cheering grows louder)
(machine winding down)